on a entendu parler des questions qu'on
commet
est-ce que tu pouvais avoir un père
c'est là où l'autre un pointe un ter qui
soit très absent qui convoie jamais que
jamais là qu'elle fait occuper mais
qu'est ministre ou un père qui est
toujours là qu'est ce qu'une super bien
de toi mais moi j'ai dit à d'abord été
magnifique
tous étaient contents de le faire alors
donc c'est quoi cette histoire je trouve
quand un papa qui est heureux il
renverra c'est bien je rassure les
parents me disent allez en espagne on
sait bien avant c'est faux bond donc tu
préfères tu es soit absent mais malgré
tout elles sont pucées d'absence n'est
pas une histoire de temps si tu sens que
tu es droite une noble quand tu sens que
quelqu'un t'aime moi si tu le vois pas
et se fait que tu sache et que personne
n'est content a vendu ses fils alors tes
activités de fait quoi en ce moment et
coutances manche entre un motif et de la
distribution d'un journal mars moscou 81
dans un journal qui fait part envers max
qui s'appelle européen
ouais c'est un journal qui va être
diffusé sur toute l'europe c'est le
premier journal européen le premier
premier dans le monde et des journées
bien européen est-ce que tu préférerais
être très reconnu de son vivant que tu
deviennes
ils ont une super patronne de presse
solution parce que tu très reconnu dans
tous les journaux toutes les télés bon
et puis quand tu meurs c'est
complètement oublié ou alors est-ce que
tu préfère ne pas être connu du tout de
ton vivant et une fois que tu es mort je
sais pas peut-être 50 ans après tu est
reconnu comme un des grands génies du
manic je passais à la reconnaissance
posthume
tu préfères être connu 50 ans après
comme un des grands jamais dû gagner ce
soir
je voudrais pouvoir apporter des choses
maintenant ouais au monde avec ce que je
sais faire c'est faire des choses et
puis éventuellement et faire partie de
ce qui peut faire progressivement vous
donc après ma mort
elles sont je m'en fous parce que tu
serais prête à mourir là comme ça tu
vois là oui si d'un seul coup tous les
petits éthiopien pouvez manger à leur
faim
mais c'est absurde c'est une question de
ses comptes en vue mais c'est comme ça
c'est le jeu c'est à ne pas traiter du
beurre instantanément oui et puis c'est
que pendant tout le temps en ethiopie en
plein de blé plein 2 tu crois la
réincarnation
je ne sais pas mais je crois en le bien
je congèle incarner mais je crois que je
crois c'est tâches liées à l'histoire de
ce que l'histoire de scorsese profondeur
c'est pas digne de l'évangile
c'est pas une question ça c'est que le
christ a enseigné aimez vous les uns les
autres à venir et que il vient justement
enseigner la différence qu'il fallait
respecter les différences dans justement
d on parle de la tentation du christ il
a précisément je me souviens parce que
j'ai relu justement à propos de ce
scandale
nous avons aussi dans l'évangile de
saint matthieu dieu devient le temps
trois fois le trou dans du verre et
comme grands mystiques la plus grasse
tentation c'est pas la tentation de la
chair c'est la tentation en inscrire et
justement dans les dans les évangiles
n'y a pas la tentation de la chair mais
à la tentation d'esprit du pouvoir chose
puis de poser la question qu'on empêche
tout ce que tu aimes
voilà et donc tout ce que font ces gens
en dessous permet jeudi qu'il interdise
les autres interprétations c'est aller à
l'encontre même de la parole du trésor
si tu étais réincarner ce que tu
préfères être réincarné en marylin
monroe ou marguerite duras marilyn
monroe
nous avons alors imagine maintenant ta
mère rentre dans ta chambre par hasard
arrivée elle doit taper bon imaginez
leur hôtel où l'attend salle peut lui
arriver
qu'est ce qui te fait le plus sont qui
est un mec dans la champ qui est deux
mecs ou une fille ce qui te fait le plus
longue
aussi c'est avec à une fille tu préfères
qu'elle te vois avec domaines définis à
qui tu trouve le plus de circonstances
atténuantes hitler staline ou polpot
personnes ok ok et entre jarrie skis et
pinochet
c'est plus compliqué là je crois que
c'est pinochet confusion mentale
donc il faut plus de circonstances
atténuantes à gérer les skis café
mâchoire en plus indifférent tu sais
c'est trop c'est trop long c'est
pourquoi bon média tg du cri aujourd'hui
bon alors dernière question cette fois
ci tu étais maîtres du monde
sa maîtresse du monde ensuite été dieux
du foot citez moi j'adore les missiles
si tu étais dieu pour san pour cinq
minutes disant tu mettrais la france ou
sur la mappemonde la wanna je laisserais
où elle est est ce que les chiffres sont
là où elles sont si on a choisi d'aimer
place et qu'elles vont bien
je mettrai pas dans le pacifique où ils
sont et évolueront je te pose même pas
la question pour marie avoir bouche tout
salon m